12 platz lars und cathay pacific airways
which caught 8 ich hab dann artikel im
internet entdeckt namen wie can not very
first class plain kevin ihr vielleicht
wisst bin ich ausschaue business class
geflogen
ich habe mich gefreut wie ein
honigkuchenpferd sich da drin sagt
jedenfalls war es bei mir halten
business class flug von frankfurt nach
new york und ich mit einem kumpel und
wir konnten wir viel essen und trinken
wie wir wollten und wir konnten alles
mögliche schauen und werden weiter alles
am start ist allerdings dass sich diese
artikel die nicht auf business class
kevin sondern auch für mein gott er hat
eine eigene bar in seiner kabine der
artikel bezieht sich auf 5 klar kabinen
ist nochmal treffer als business class
und business class hätte ich da drin
sagt ich dachte schon bin ich schon 7000
himmel oder möchte den bürgern den kopf
aber wir schauen uns sich artikel mal an
quarterback parts about having experten
man i had to be flying teil das ist
natürlich logisch wenn man ganz viel
geld hatten geiste das liegen
alle plain cambridge special event
rampling international queen 9 90
prozent aller studenten leben in wien
haben mich meine eigene dusche
wag
butler im flugzeug sie haben ein kundin
zeitwert eine persönliche dusche und
einen butler kadetten return the
experience around auf jeden fall
ich meine natürlich bevor man jetzt
irgendwie kam ich bin ja schon mal
economy class nach new york geflogen da
war es echt ey du eigentlich konnte ich
beim ersten kind gekocht und die haben
einfach ein queensberry personal schauer
und butler und dann wahrscheinlich noch
beschweren skoda und follower die
treasurys first class kevin 23 zoll
displays bis die großen display bahn
economy class
so gut vielleicht vielleicht so
ja irgendwie so aber niemals 23 zoll
altarbild control würde touchscreen
remote control located in die zieht
kommt wahrscheinlich auch einen
touchscreen remote hör ich musste da
knöpfe drücken wie sonne und an alle
leute die irgendwie jedem aussage von
mir wörtlich nehmen dass hier überhaupt
nicht ein video deinen von wegen mir geh
zur scheiße und anderen fördert gerührt
ich will ein bisschen abreagieren weil
dadurch wie hätte das denn
juli vor soviel hat mein macbook nicht
mal und irgendein flugzeug ende personen
locker der kampf wurde müller vor
inflight touch ab okay das heißt sie
haben sogar an ihrem an ihrem sitzplatz
noch einschlief warum braucht man wenn
man in der first class ist und dort die
ganze zeit nur fehlt auch noch ein
persönliches lied one way ticket am
london city die usa tibet als 1000 tagen
die champions und japan airlines suite
seventy seven hell wood green and tired
and a cloud of the other weekend for the
privacy das heißt sie können das hier
wohl dazu machen damit ihre eigenen
privatsphäre vergangenheit wie bei platz
zehn
wir hatten den artikel geschrieben
nummer so zum vergleich das hier ist
economy essen irgendwo was in so einer
schale in seinen zehn jahre alte
brötchen dann kommen wir premium economy
denkt nicht man dafür schon ein bisschen
schöner der wir dann kommen die vertrat
ich hab noch nie so gut gegessen platz
nummer achtet er fast auf das lag primär
ob jacob matschenz 1000 dollar leute
dort auch wenn ich noch so 4 millionen
euro machen würde
die 1000 dollar in einer first class
flug kann doch nicht länger dauern als
irgendwie war 10 15 stunden oder 10.000
dollar
das sind das sind 1000 pizzen das wissen
wochen vorrat bei mir bekannt wurde
produktion where you can't turn into
that you can take advantage of excess of
sales und technik hautnah wird
wahrscheinlich guckt euch das bild an
und das alles in der luft qatar airways
first class wie brückenkopf über 5000
dollar tree kleinen zur flat werdegang
wurde das ist ein paar sekunden später
wurde von daunen bettdecke customer not
present to take advantage of qatar
airways sky lounge wettkampf mit curt
war ein paar snacks die handelbar
im flugzeug eine bar im flugzeug hatte
hendrik otto 15.000 dollar fünf leute
wenn ich irgendwann mal geld in so einem
fall class flug stecken würden
arma 2 -freien die bekommen auch noch
alles geschenkt
augenscheinlich trinken sie auch noch
ein porsche geschenkt wenn du dann
wieder am boden sind unten butler
natürlich weil man sich selber hinkriegt
diesen knopf zu drücken
bitte schließt man hat nicht nur eine
menge geld man ist anscheinend auch sv
veert sich sowas können okay leute okay
manchmal werden wenn man das buch kriegt
man vor dem flug auch noch eine massage
ist das noch irgendwas sagen ich fühle
mich gar nicht so aufregend darüber dass
wir noch einigermaßen normal aber ich
meine dass diese auch guy lauter was
derzeit nicht so geil aus wie das vorhin
mit einem butler und mittelbar vorne
drin und alle first class flyers und
cathay pacific airways virgin kurz
[Musik]
achten fall auch einen eigenen tv eigene
pyjamas eigene lcd-touchscreen dass man
sogar die nicht da kontrollieren kann
blatt preis ein parkplatz weiter
emirates von dubai in new york in fonds
an bord auf 9000 okay das ist jetzt
gerade wo wir gerade 28.000 hatten schon
so ein bisschen minimum er you can take
advantage of your own minibar
ach ja das hatten wir ja gerade oben
schon im beispiel die beim hessel
selection of bulgari tolle triefend
timeless barth product schaut euch das
an da ist dass es nicht wahr
das ist das
wahrscheinlich wird das gemälde auch
noch persönliche von pkv dorthin
gezeichnet ich will niemanden hätten der
kauft oder der das halt macht aber hey
ich will auf platz nummer zwei drei und
singapore airlines mit akribie bet at
home at
das ist
da
das ist das ist in einem flugzeug leute
stellt euch das vorliegt jemand drin
sie haben auch einen extra matratzen
popper noch braucht damit noch
gemütlicher sind 100 radicals libyens
biotech entwendet
hat man also auch noch ein jugendlicher
vor airlines judosport 18.000 dollar und
dann sieht das so aus
mein gott gelächelt einfach nur an eurer
stelle für den champagner hat mir direkt
in den mund kippen und alles zerstört
und party machen da drin halter aber
okay wir kommen jetzt zu platz nummer 1
etihad airways die national youth syria
flat option
doch die importe experience göttin am
sterbebett und personalchef walcott
30.000
30.000 ein weg von einer stadt zur
anderen bezahlen leute das 30-fache von
dem normalen preis für diesen flug damit
sie ein paar stunden ihres lebens
komfort haben
das ins krank man kann halt auch richtig
geilen penny ist das nicht das ist das
ist das badezimmer persönliche
badezimmer die gross sitzen das flugzeug
patti hat kevin really get the black
series of it gets alters hat euch das an
ich meine das ist doch nicht weg das ist
nicht normal
ohne spaß das sieht einfach nur noch
krank aus alter kann man hier mit dem
bildschirm die wände dieser holz ablage
wahrscheinlicher planen eine eigene bar
in heftigen sessel und alle say leute
echtes einmal machen wollte dann werde
ich meinen kanal schließen
real talk dass das ist das ist doch viel
zu krank das war der heute von video
meine damen und herren ich wollte diesen
artikel einfach zusammen mit euch durch
lesen weil ich den gewinn hatte und dann
hab ich mir gedacht das den locker
krasse sachen drin vielleicht kannst du
deine leute auf einmal daran teilhaben
wenn ihr noch mal was wohl dass ich
irgendwas krasse vorstelle weil für mich
ist das halt auch mega spaßig und
notwendiger wenn ich noch mal machen
wollt dann lasst mal vier frauen
gleichen look crew community
bullshit
die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf klickt
abonniert dem einen kanal mit
kostenlosen apps keine videos mehr da
oben findet auch mein job eingeblendet
wo ihr mädchen das von mir kaufen können
und hier ist irgendein anderes video
verlinkt
red like button